das ist ziemlich geil mit dem schwert
haut habt ihr teilweise innerhalb von
drei sekunden so eine ganze xp leiste
voll das ist das ist schon ziemlich
krass da könnt ihr also bevor das spiel
losgeht einfach schon mal zehn level
oder so auf jeden fall die täglich
zeigen wollte ist der
leute und herzlich willkommen zu den
ernte games heute werde ich euch einen
geilen trick vorstellen mit dem
fehlenden roll back heißt es übersehen
die seelen zählt die mitarbeitenden
dennis und sowie tag grüßt euch jetzt
schon wieder behindert so alle töten
mich immer oder du oder nicht ich glaube
du bist ich gehe ich bin ich nehme mir
alles weg alles einfach alles einfach
keine gefunden
drüben ist man endlich ein ende des
sommers sind euch einige stücke sehr
geil durchaus geil
wisst ihr leute zu mittag isst der
beschissenes die youtuber den man sich
vorstellen kann
aber wenn er die schnauze hält dann bin
ich total dennis du lachst das nicht
lustig muss sagen dass ich kein
superspiel
wieder sollte mir gegeben ja wo ist der
nächste alter um sind die am anfang
alles egal
wollte eigentlich sinn größte kommt den
er nicht mehr will ich jetzt habe ich
ein bisschen platz perfekt machen jetzt
erstmal eine schöne lions auf jeden fall
die trägt nicht zeigen wollte ist der
wenn ihr mit dem kit seelen dieb in der
vorbereitungsphase leute haut kriegt ja
schon xp so das ist ziemlich geil wäre
dem schwert haut habt ihr teilweise
innerhalb von drei sekunden so eine
ganze xp leiste voll das ist das schon
ziemlich krass da könnt ihr also bevor
das spiel losgeht einfach schon mal zehn
level oder so holen das ist keine
seltenheit und dann müsst ihr halt im
spiel nicht mehr so dumpf armen seelen
dessen seele die mich mal hierhin kommt
erhält der müssen wir lieber kämpfen
weiß gar nicht dass ich nur fünf herzen
hat der erste schlagbaum an land birner
und der pakt fluggesellschaft auf ok 50
pro ak 50 blöcke kein ding
nee das ist eine spur von von dem
anderen darf ist schon bescheid
ich find ich ja was haben uns hier noch
schönes kräften
ach ja wir können vor allem mal hier
noch ein paar animals la hoya hacker so
ennemoser style.com
jetzt haben wir schon aus einer
heimischen fast 2 level rausgeholt und
verzaubert jetzt mal unserer leggins
protection 1 sehr geil
wer wer von euch seit ich mit minecraft
nerd genug um genau zu sagen was
protection 1 bringt also genau was
bringt genau protection bringt joachim
aber wie viel die 1
ein schutz geschützt heute schutz wie
komme ich hab protection einsatz auf
leggins und hermann und das geil ist man
kann sich wirklich dumm und dämlich
verzaubert mit dem seele die pid ja das
alte hinter mir einfach keinen bock
drauf
hohoho natürlich alter schwede nicht
kommt ja erst mal bisschen hier
ich maße mir am liebsten so ich kämpfe
nicht so gerne bis ich mich mal richtig
ausgestattet haben weil er kann immer
mal passieren dass ihr ein geratet der
richtig gut aus script ist und euch über
weghaut deswegen war ich am liebsten so
lange bis ich mal ein halbwegs trieb ab
und volle leben
und ja weil er dann richtig rein ja das
ist der klassische sks parade so
unfassbar laut ist ja ja ja ja ja oder
hättest du mich ja ich bin tot
hier ist aber gestorben und hatte nur
bullshit egal
mäßig der nächste stück entfernt bis 50
könnte man dir helm 86 die affen dir
brustpanzer kassenbon oder wien
da kommt mal wieder der kirche sowie tag
einfach richtig anderen würfeln der rede
ich bin nicht so drauf ist eine kiste
bier rechts und zwei freuen
neben dir habe ich schon blutet es ist
jetzt natürlich wissen verwirrend für
euch das hier unser kollege daneben an
der suuri tag im bett das wenig smw
zockt mw 3 4 5 6 7
die ändert es ist so eine ewig große
ebene
die sind einfach keine die kuh schaf das
kommt mir bitte noch einen diamanten die
spitze
in dem moment nämlich an iran will ja ja
ja ja die perfekt ja ich hab 385 ideal
hoffentlich werde ich jetzt nicht mein
blog in der hand
machst du dir einfach ich hab die ganze
zeit
ich habe die ganze zeit auf diesen
scheiß des spanischen eins drauf perfekt
auf jeden fall wieder ein abgang
was für ein opfer blutiger hab ich ihm
gegeben
der war ja das kommt aber auch davon
wenn ich ging leute ich will muss die in
der faq benutzen alternativ geholt
er hat sich einfach eine original boot
gekauft hätten
kommt noch ein kind und ich hab
protection drauf läuft alter leute ich
sage euch ne das ist so pös dieses ding
und power 1 auf meinem bogen alter
richtig geil ich habe sieben männer
dabei ist einfach jemand genauso wie der
deutlich verpasst ihr mit meiner
limburger berechnung gehen
das ist ein fucking känguru yahoo die
strategie ist doch so neu als känguru
weg springen und dann mit dem bogen
drauf schließlich sei nicht dumm junge
wächst du kannst mich zu treffen was zu
sagen hätte nicht treffen
naja das war jetzt ein bisschen viel ich
gekämpft ich hab mich gewundert euch
gefallen nächste mal bringe ich wieder
eine runde durch gewinne ja das
bekanntlich muss selber gewähren die
sich gefallen gibt einen daumen nach
oben und traktion in die kommentare
ich fahre ich nicht gefallen hat kritik
falls ihr seid ja es kay gewinn doch mal
alle runden die du spielst du dann
schreibt mir dass die kommentare oder
was sie aber durch den kopf geht
ihr wisst ja ich beantworte alle
kommentare bester youtubes und so ja
leute macht's mal gut